[Music]
I am Dave Anthony I'm here with my
friend Gareth Reynolds I invited him
over to my house we're in my bedroom and
I thought that we would watch I don't
let me stop you I don't think it's fair
to lie to people so we have known I want
to show you is the vegetable mystery
vegetable mystery rolls off the tongue
all right made by the Fleischer brothers
the Fleischer shirt came from Austria
but you know about that yeah yeah those
are the Austrian guys for sure okay what
year are we dealing with 1939 okay this
is gonna color why did it take so long
for them to realize you could color
cartoons paramount max where's the other
brother they were having a falling-out
at this point X is an [ __ ] they've
directed it I like the idea of directed
cartoons fellas fellas too big more
carrots come on your eyes are buggin out
the fresh vegetable mystery okay and
you'll see what the mystery is okay so
education sure obviously what vegetables
do when you are sleeping I didn't think
they did this did you do this so the
carrot is cooking other vegetables the
carrot is just using the lettuce to keep
warm
potatoes patties potatoes ah so these
potatoes obviously are Irish
yep Irish cop that's a glory hole to be
honest okay okay so the clock is even
so four days went by four days and now
Oh No guys get out of there
Oh little baby carrots oh no that prick
says a kidney wasn't kidnapping yeah
okay well you could be taking this a
little better I mean the thing is your
vegetables if someone's gonna take us
[ __ ] oh oh yeah drink a beer Irish
potato I don't know he's looking for
he's already got a match
wow that came out of nowhere this guy's
playing at another level this is like
the ISIS of cartoons he's a bad cop what
is this thing
so all hell's breaking loose he thinks
he's getting shot at yeah he is getting
shot at they busted a cap at him so
obviously now he's forked this cop is
super numbered yeah although it is a
better philosophy than what we have now
with cops where he would just be
blasting bullets at all the carrots okay
guys is he a real cop you enjoying the
mystery all right I forgot that's a
mystery I don't want to sound like this
guy but behind you whistle the whistle
could come in handy along yeah they are
not organized okay so what happened was
the cops the cop got attacked right so
now they're gonna know yeah is he saying
police are saying it could be so they're
literally torturing this guy by putting
him in a toaster
it's a drug for no reason of course
they're pickled onions frying the old
shell game I mean if you have a good
line illegal interrogation between
potato cops Oh a turn okay so now now
they're mad yeah now they're upset
they've been massive it's all traps dude
are you scaring idiot he deserves to be
hashbrown I would eat that oh that's not
good ah yes that going well for the cops
I mean that guy these guys are just not
I mean they're not professional yeah but
Egbe now they're gonna beat the eggs
yeah they'd beaten every other thing in
the kitchen no they got the egg beater
what's gonna happen now with side one
after oh you bastards they're mice the
classic enemy of potatoes they're
turning on each other yeah
who isn't an [ __ ] I mean this is
basically about police brutality and how
police it's a little heavy against the
Irish yeah oh it's definitely the Irish
definitely takes some shrapnel but
that's I mean the whole thing is just
that the police beat up everyone in
question to everyone it's a mystery it's
a mouse turn it's so if there's a
mystery the cops just get to beat the
[ __ ] out of people I'm glad we've
changed this is a long time ago yeah and
that doesn't happen in him no now well
yeah now if now if like a potato is
chasing some like vegetable it runs away
it just shoots the [ __ ] out of it right
good god any notes I have a lot of no I
think it's perfect I think that they I
think that Irish police are portrayed as
drunks and that's not okay I think that
pickled onions are well a lot of the
vegetables are drunk which is
problematic that but that's you know
we're gonna do also they didn't even
process them when they went into the
jail all right I just threw him in there
I don't know if they have processing of
mice again this is a this is a like a
pantry mm-hmm yeah it's not actually a
police station well look I get him video
I can do yeah I get invested where was
the meat you ever talked to the steak
maybe maybe put a hot light on the
ribeye for a second see what his deal is
hmm I just think that's a that's let's
wait for the sequel excited I think we
should have cut like a minute ago or
something
[Music]
you